i'm also wick first i'm a professor of
philosophy at stockholm university
um i work in philosophy of mind and
language and epistemology and i've
written a book
in swedish so far called alternative
facts on knowledge and its enemies
i'm going to start with the question
what are alternative facts
well they don't exist obviously i mean
facts are
concerned how the world is for example
it's a fact that
today it's been quite warm here at this
festival
um alternative facts are what people
might mean when they talk about that
is alternative descriptions are reality
they're not true
um so no there are no alternative facts
so what's the relationship between
alternative facts and fake news well
fake news i mean what's going on now
right is that we have a lot of
alternative descriptions of reality
and there's a lot of struggle about
whose description is
the right one fake news play into that
because fake news often wants to push a
certain kind of message
it's not the the piece of news itself
there's a larger overall
message they want to push in sweden fake
news is almost always about immigration
so that there's a message there that's
pushed so fake news
play are used to make people believe
certain things have happened certain
events that support this larger message
that one wants to spread
such as um that immigration is making
sweden
uh on the verge of a collapse
that kind of thing um yeah so when we're
talking about
politicized alternative facts like fake
news it's easy to fact check and say
when something is wrong
but more broadly is there an objective
truth
yes depending on what you mean right
so truth is the property of what we say
or what we believe
and it's certainly objective in this
sense that
whether or not what i say has that
property
it's not up to me and it's not up to you
and it's not up to
everybody's opinion so we can all think
that they you know
maybe people that at some point all
think that the earth was flat
it didn't make it true so in that sense
truth is objective
what about plato's cave then the way in
which we
[Music]
analyze operate record facts and
consider
what is objective truth might be
undermined by our subjective
understanding of that surely well i mean
we are not objective very often right we
are
biased and flawed in all sorts of ways
when it comes to cognition
we have very partial understanding of
things and this is what plato was
talking a lot about how we often don't
quite properly understand things
or grasp ideas um so we are flawed
but that doesn't sort of affect the
property of truth but it does mean that
it's really hard for us to get the truth
and
in particular it's really hard for us to
know that we got into truth
so a lot of people when they say there's
no truth what they really mean is there
is no certainty
uncertainty is hard to come by and i
think that is the sort of main lesson of
the history of
epistemology the history of skepticism
all going back to antiquity where
we live in the predicament is this right
we have our beliefs
and we want to reach truth and we base
our beliefs on evidence or reasons
or grounds or something but the reasons
and the grounds
are almost never conclusive you know
outside of philosophy and
i mean outside of logic and mathematics
you don't have proofs
what you have is more or less strong
evidence but even when your evidence is
really strong
skepticism shows you can kind of drive a
wedge in there
so you can make people doubt even when
you have very strong reasons
and this possibility of doubt is
something we live with this is our human
predicament when it comes to beliefs
about the external world
and um so yeah we don't have certainty
we strive for truth but we should always
be open to the possibility that we are
wrong
and that's precisely the point of
stressing that truth is objective
it's not up to me which means it's not
up to me to decide
so i have to be open for the possibility
that i am wrong and i have to listen to
objections and to other people but can
we only
reach as difficult it is to do so the
conclusion of what is an objective truth
through a materialist analysis
like the scientific method or other ways
of understanding what truths are
well like i said what truths are is one
thing and how we reach them
is another scientific method has proven
a really good way
to approach truth to reach truth even
though we rarely get certainty that way
either
but it's not you know we know all sorts
of things in our daily lives you know i
know things about other people's
emotions
not because i have some experiment i've
done with them but because i
i observe them and see them and know
them so we know things in all sorts of
ways
although i think this sort of way we
think in daily life it's not that
different from
from scientific way of thinking so if
you
i come up on you and you seem really
upset i form a hypothesis oh
maybe he's upset because i didn't you
know do this or that
and then i checked that hypothesis by
asking you so
we sort of use the scientific method in
daily life
even though of course it's not the way
of the you know natural sciences and so
on it's not that far apart i think
so why do people accept
alternative truths or facts speaking the
political sphere perhaps
well so there are a few things right in
general first again like i said it can
be really hard to determine whether
something is true or not
you get something from a source that you
think is reliable
and you believe it so maybe you're
relying on this source is misplaced
but from your point of view when it
comes from that source there's a reason
to believe it and you accept it and
that's not so strange
but then of course there are other sort
of psychological things that play in
there
there's confirmation bias so we like to
confirm
our prior beliefs we have a tendency to
do that so if a piece of fake
news comes that fits with my world view
i'd be very very inclined to
accept it and from my my point of view
might even be rational it fits right in
there is emotion right when when a
statement comes to me that kind of makes
me feel good
makes my feeling of you know who i'm at
who i am
and my sense of group identity and so it
fits right in um
i'm i'm inclined to accept it so there
are all sorts of psychological emotional
and cognitive biases
that interact with disinformation coming
to us in a very dangerous way
so how then do we equip people with the
tools to resist
propaganda fake news alternative truths
conspiracy theories in this post-truth
world
well it's hard right because like i mean
people say oh
people should just think for themselves
now that's not a universal solution
first of all
if you think for yourself and know very
little it's not going to go so well
so i think critical thinking especially
philosophers tank
tend to think it's this superpower that
we solve all the problems
but we know that critical thinking
doesn't work that way
critical thinking is domain specific so
if i try to think for myself in an area
like biology that i don't know much
about it's not going to go so well
i need to actually get knowledge to be a
good critical thinker
so to think that ah the solution is if
people were just more critical it would
go well
that's way too naive i think and and and
in fact
the real true person who thinks for
themselves completely is the conspiracy
theorist right so it's not really the
way to go
but of course people need to learn to be
critical in their attitudes and not
believe everything that comes to them
it's just
um that it's it's not it's not a simple
solution
and what we have to do i think a media
knowledge is very important
so the kind of knowledge of you know how
does
a reliable source work what's
distinctive of a source or an
institution
that's more reliable than one that's not
well there are internal checks and
balances on institutions that work
better than others
so we have to sort of think about our
institutions and how they function
and we have to keep them honest and make
sure they do a good job so
there's both the sort of individual sort
of
ways of thinking and being critical to a
point
and sort of making sure that our
institutions function the way they're
supposed to do
then there's the role of technology and
that is a huge one
and uh it's very likely that we need
legislation to make that work better
um but it's it's a challenge we can't
legislate away
false content that would be a very bad
idea we have to do it in other ways
so on the topic of our institutions
it's the societal infrastructure whether
that's the education sector whether that
is
new and emerging technologies is that in
place to teach
the necessary critical thinking no i
think we cannot we don't know what to do
right now i think it's a really
difficult situation
i mean look each time communication
language is at the essence of what it is
to be a human being
we use language to cooperate to uh
transfer knowledge from individual to
individuals it's central to us
so each time there's a new way of
communicating new technology for
communication
society go through radical
transformations you know you've got the
printing press and you've got the
reformation as a result some historians
say right
and we got the new newspapers we got
liberal democracy
you know step and step with that and
when the radio came the nazis used that
to promote propaganda so we're now
in the infancy of a new technology that
we don't know how to handle
we just cannot fail flailing right
uh we will maybe figure out how to do
that but it might take a little while
right that's real problem yeah um then
to wrap up
what is the future that you would like
to see
in relation to the way in which people
accept criticize
fats that are presented to them
well i mean i'd like us to have a
society where we have reliable
knowledge institutions as it were where
the academy works the way it should be
without
you know cheating in their research and
all that stuff
where media established media does a
serious work at
giving a nuanced picture of what's going
on and where we have ways
of uh weeding out the worst kind of
disinformation sources
in combination with education which
prepares people to
handle because that's going to stay with
us handle the multiplicity
of sources of information that we now
have we can we can't go back to a
situation where we had a few reliable
sources it was easy enough right
we can't go back to that we're going to
have a multiplicity and you need
to teach children and young people how
to handle that
multiplicity so they find the reliable
sources and trust those
and are able to resist the others and
that's a super big challenge but i think
schools are now thinking a lot about
this so i'm hopeful that that will also
be something that we can do
also of course thank you very much for
your time thank you